this is Kenya's Americana branch it's
owned collectively by about 10,000 Masai
and it's also the hunting grounds for
dozens of lion families or prides that
are disappearing quickly the Messiah the
Lions have a tense coexistence some
Lions prey upon the cattle that sustain
them a size nomadic lifestyle the Maasai
kill lions suspected of killing their
cattle and of late the lion population
has dipped to a dangerously low level
that's a matter of deep concern to
National Geographic explorers and
residents dereck and Beverly shoe bear
the lands dip below 200 200 men
sidelines and a few years ago and I
think they're probably down to about 130
250 now those sort of declines of not
sustaining will get to a point where
probably the next 10 or 12 kills will
determine whether the lands will survive
or not I mean if you take a 10 male
lands out of the population of 130 there
are no more male lands they say ways
must be found to discourage herders from
killing lions by providing economic
incentives
it's a Ketel dependent economy for the
Maasai people so every car that they
lose really hurts them economically and
it makes sense that they would want to
go out and eradicate all the lands in
the area as a result so the whole system
has to change you have to allow them to
have the economy coming from the lines
as well and as soon as they have that
they will to be the protectors of the
lands of become their heritage and their
income a new conservation program pays
the Maasai to protect the lions rather
than kill them the key is keeping tabs
on where the lines are located on the
ranch
using a receiver to pick up signals from
a radio collar attached around the necks
of various lion pride members they're
able to monitor lion activity cell
phones enable them to alert others when
the Lions are around so the Messiah can
move their herds elsewhere they can also
alert authorities if they discover
hunters are trying to kill any of the
animals in addition there's also a trust
that compensates ranchers whose
livestock has been killed or injured by
the cats the multi-pronged approach has
worked wonders there are now far fewer
lion killings on the em bear Connie
ranch than in other areas in Maasai land
but more needs to be done and done
quickly the key is to make the lines
more valuable alive to the Masai than
dead
National Geographic along with the zoo
bears has created an emergency fund to
help avert the complete loss of lines in
the Masai land of southern Kenya the
fund will help create jobs for the Masai
people support education and
conservation efforts and promote cattle
raising solutions they will become the
ambassadors for the Masson lines in the
area and of course they will also have a
bigger revenue because they'd have more
tourism coming into the area Lions or
iconic lions are really what bring
tourism to wilderness areas and so they
need them never before has the plight of
the Masai lines been more urgent and
without increased intervention they may
lose these majestic animals all too soon
there's been a big impact and it's and
it's on such a decline that within three
to five years we will we will have no
lines there and this we step in and do
something right now